if somebody said predict what your
grandchildren do for a living I would
say one of them's a hundred percent of
psychologists cuz they'll take my DNA
but they'll be part of a rich family
which means they have to be a
psychologist and the reason I say it is
so they can watch it me like [ __ ] you
got your prospective here in London
early morning and ek is here which is so
right rare to see him outside of that
little eight foot area
[Music]
if you rock and I just talking we put up
like like seven of like nine videos on
Instagram over the last week
hit over a million views which is
incredibly strong metrics for my page
and literally two days ago in the office
I'm like guys you've got this totally
[ __ ] figured out and no joke
yesterday we posted every writer faculty
yesterday literally we posted a video
that was the worst performing video
we've posted in yeah see in a little bit
how to finance here one day
literally the worst piece of [ __ ]
content we put up two things on that one
that's why this game's the best and just
like confidence humility algorithms
audience putting out content highs lows
we all go through them I I was telling
the guys I loved it so I love getting
touched the mouth more importantly
number two when I posted it I knew it
wasn't gonna overly perform intuitively
I was like this is just not the kind of
stuff that goes viral on Instagram but
it was probably one of the more
important pieces of content I put out of
like the balance of like you know
optimism and actually putting in the
work and it reminded me of the Thank You
economy my least selling book that I've
written but arguably to me like
philosophically the most important book
I've written so you know what some
answer or if you're up there no worries
no this is it you'll be in it
that's just how sometimes it works like
like depth a lot of times it's way more
meaningful than with and I just really
wish more people would wrap their head
around it especially in the context of a
post on Instagram where the [ __ ] does
that mean in your life like being upset
all day because you didn't get enough
likes or views as neutral
[Music]
guys you knew you do agree with me that
we haven't spent enough time talking
about the fact that my college went out
of business like it folded after like a
hundred plus years it doesn't exist
[Music]
the biggest thing Robbie that you guys
need to think about is none of this is
contextualized for a different economy
and that's the best part of this whole
thing everything you just said is
awesome
it becomes awesomer when everything
melts and there is no side funds for
four years and everyone is dying because
what ends up happening just to tell you
how it actually is gonna play out is
this will all work better because people
gonna make smarter decisions because
they don't have the money to make dumb
decisions and as it gets more money it's
gonna self fund itself to be able to buy
things that are already like do not mean
whose brand to run a business to over
level
[Music]
lotta funny baby bring the bottle and
booze so here's what's gonna happen when
the world melts it's 18 p.m. BMW and
Evian and Tesco organ hire vaynermedia
because what's gonna happen is their
marketing budgets gonna go from a
hundred million to twelve and they're
going to need that twelve to work really
hard and we're established as knowing
how to do that
and the only reason people don't go with
us now is because money's easy and they
don't have to do the right work so they
can give the money to their buddy or the
person that takes them to [ __ ] in the
Manchester United game on the field got
it when they can't do that anymore
they're gonna give it all to us I'm
gonna get all that so this machine that
is stupid now gets really smart because
we'll go from 280 to 590 in revenue in
24 months it'll be profitable revenue
because the world will melt and I'll be
able to hire all the people from other
agencies for 25 cents on the dollar at
the same time a bunch of companies are
going to be over leveraged and I'm gonna
go out of business and I'm gonna be able
to buy those businesses with the cash
flow of the 590 at higher revenue then
the economy will turn back in 12 years
and I'll be able to sell those
businesses at the frothy end and buy the
Jets Super Bowls you see what I'm doing
I'm playing the reverse game so
everybody thinks it's stupid now because
they don't understand it's over valued
then it's gonna seem very smart and then
I'm gonna show this video and be like it
wasn't an accident
which will only compound the smarts of
it and I'll be 62 and have 40 years to
play all on the equity of like pulling
off a billion-dollar thing on smarts not
luck on humility of eating [ __ ] for a
decade in my prime
right like kids are gonna watch these
videos and be like he was [ __ ] 39 he
was 42 like I'm 26 and he was patient
that's why it worked I'm gonna do
nobody's ever seen anybody play it we
didn't get to watch Steve Jobs his first
nine years and not that I'm mad or this
and that it's just like we didn't get to
see Bezos packing books no powerful and
B right now how many views do you think
how many you know how many views do you
think if Jeff Bezos was doing
those first 50 episodes of impacting
books in a [ __ ] garage would have a
80 million maybe a 14 billion right
everybody would watch it I mean
everybody yeah so how'd you like to
watch Michael Jordan's first three off
seasons and the work he put in so
there's a lot of thought that goes into
what I do that I don't speak about or I
show glimpses of and things like this my
team talks a lot about like me not
talking about being smart as you guys
know like none of my content is
predicated on being smart that's just
gonna speak for itself when it's also
not I don't need people to
[Music]
[Music]
I couldn't I couldn't take the current
state of the education mortgage I the
level of disrespect I have for it is
extraordinary all they're the only good
places are trading on brand and it's
because it's the insecurity of the
professor's of not realizing they can do
it themselves direct-to-consumer which
has only got another ten years
there is no Cambridge there's no Harvard
there's the individuals teaching within
it and the second that they wake up and
realize they have the leverage is the
same reason I think the MBA could
actually fold I am inside I have a crazy
thesis on the MBA
I think the MBA is so top-heavy to the
top 15 stars and that they sit with all
the leverage that if you look at them
now if you look at the LeBron and d-wade
and these guys and right they're all
friends they're all doing business
together they're different than what I
grew up with Larry Bird and Jordan were
they hated each other I think the next
version is they're gonna collude and
break the league right now if LeBron
down to Greek freak the 12 best players
in the league also then paired up with a
billionaire and said let's start a new
league on LeBron you're Russian oligarch
I'm Kevin Durant you're a tech you're
Mark Zuckerberg
let's we're gonna leave we're gonna
start a new MBA I own 50% of the team as
LeBron you own 50% of the team Kevin
Systrom we're now the Los Angeles
loophole and like all you need left the
only thing that's left is just having a
stadium that will take you and that's
where some of the team's control that
other than that they actually have no
leverage that is not true and proper
football that is not true in baseball
that is not true in a lot of other
places in the NBA it is and it's the
strength of the NBA and it will be the
demise of the NBA I'm a hundred percent
right about this it's it's inevitable it
has to happen what is most interesting
to me is when the stuff has happened but
people don't see it yet but you don't
even have to guess like Shopify and
Amazon has happened yet they don't
believe it's happened like it's in your
fate like
people always ask me like what's next
I'm like I have no idea but the second I
see it I'll probably be the fastest and
loudest to talk about it and then you
think I'm guessing or predicting I
watched snapchat for 15 months before I
publicly went on the snapchat is here
and everybody in the marketing world is
like he was the one that was right about
Suraj at 15 months I analyzed it and
then only after the dj khaled moment cuz
I knew it was gonna hit the zeitgeist
then I got in front of it I watched
which from the day it started literally
Justin texted me because he did Justin
TV when he started twitch I've been
watching it but only did I start talking
about it because I was forced to cuz
[ __ ] ninja and Drake had the moment
and now I knew was gonna be in the
zeitgeist I'll watch the whole time and
I'll only start speaking about my
thoughts if I'm forced to because I know
the world had tipped or I put the
container around it to then talk about
that's the transpose 100% it's what I'm
really darn good at if somebody asked me
to tell me what might if somebody said
predict what your grandchildren do for a
living I would say one of them's a
hundred percent of psychologists cuz
they'll take my DNA but they'll be part
of a rich family which means they have
to be a psychologist not an entrepreneur
positive just the way it all works s
those written in it and the reason I say
this so they can watch it be like [ __ ]
like I think I'm gonna make my family
into entrepreneurs in perpetuity
out of being ashamed of not doing the
cliched [ __ ] that I'm telling them
they're gonna do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]